hello and welcome to a special episode
of footnotes it's Star Wars week here at
Wired and instead of me revisiting
particular stories I'm going to explore
the many influences on the film's so
I'll begin by talking about the anchors
of the Star Wars films the Jedi because
in space you don't need actual anchors
George Lucas derive the term Jedi from
the Japanese GI gehrke as onra that
focuses on the 80 period of the early
1600s to mid 1800s and classic jejeje
movies such as Seven Samurai and the
innovative the less popular 6.5 samurai
are the framework for the Jedi of Star
Wars like the samurai of olden times the
Jedi are loyal to a master in this case
the Republic but when the Empire
replaces the Republic the Jedi are cast
out and become Ronin masterless samurai
that are forced to wander around helping
people get cats out of trees the Jedi
have long been in Ronin like exile when
Luke Skywalker begins his quest and it
should be noted that Luke never walked
on the sky but in fairness he did jump
pretty high ones Luke follows an arc
like many heroes before him in part
because George Lucas was heavily
influenced by book called the hero with
a thousand faces by a mythologist Joseph
Campbell who himself had only one face
according to Campbell myths the world
over share a common structure this
pattern is called the monomyth and it
applies as much the classic heroes like
Odysseus as it does to modern ones like
luke and the time i replaced the bottle
on the water cooler without spilling
of course Luke is not the only heroic
figure in the Star Wars saga there's
also the guy who bravely gave up his arm
to spice up the decor and a Maus Eisley
cantina in addition there's qui-gon jinn
who has a particularly interesting name
in a sense that he isn't a loner named
Han Solo or a meanie head named General
Grievous jinn are actually the genies of
Arabian mythology but qui-gon jinn is
only good at granting wishes that
involve dismemberment and qui gonn
likely derives from the Japanese Qi Gong
the practice of bouncing the life energy
known as Chi it's this energy that we
see mirrored in the force which
supposedly binds the universe together
but we all know that it's in fact
friendship that unites space and time
also all pervasive in the universe are
the droids r2d2 and c3po who not only
play huge roles in Star Wars but also
appear in Indiana Jones c-3po s design
was actually inspired by the robot in
the classic silent film metropolis that
robot eventually became pretty and did a
sexy dance that incited men to riot
which may well be c-3po s fate in the
upcoming Star Wars films unfortunately
it will be some time before the reboot
of the saga hits theaters but we can
reasonably expect it to include at least
seven maybe seven and a half Jedi
handling about and fighting each other
to pull cats out of trees
you